I could have used some therapy as a kid
weird kid bedwetter oh yeah I wet the
bed every day when I was 13 years old my
mattress looked like a goddamn coffee
filter
I ruined a lot of sleepovers folks yeah
you start to run out of excuses after a
while now your friend's like what
happened here I was like ah geez I must
have spilled a cup of piss
yeah they say a lot of bedwetters become
serial killers which I believe because
we learned how to clean up a stain
pretty quick
that's how embarrassing it is wetting
the bed almost rather be known as a
murderer than a bedwetter you know your
friend sits on your mattress why is it
all crinkly I'm gonna kill you